in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Brian
and allene are with us hey guys how are
you hi Dave good we're good thing
welcome welcome for do you guys live
Dalhart Texas no where's that that's
about 80 miles north of Amarillo oh wow
okay West Texas yeah cool welcome to
Nashville it's a bit of a haul to come
all the way to Nashville it is worth
every minute of it but here to do your
debt-free screen absolutely and how much
debt have you to paid off six hundred
and seventeen thousand dollars good lord
and how long did this take six months
six years and seven months six years
seven months yes they're making what
kind of money average during that time
our range well we started at about sixty
thousand dollars a year and we currently
make about a hundred and ten between the
two of us
excellent what do you guys do for a
living I'm the associate pastor at a
Baptist Church mm-hmm and I'm a branch
campus director of a community college
Oh awesome
very cool so I'm guessing then the
length of this and the amount that this
must have been your house and everything
yes you paid off your how old are you
too old
no you're not I'll be 55 this year
you're young and I am 51 all right well
you're super young yeah he robbed the
cradle yeah okay excellent and you're
you don't have a house payment yes you
are officially weird we are we are I
love it people right here in my lobby
yeah I mean not having a house payments
weird it is very strange yes it's a
strange so tell me the story what
happens six years and seven months ago
I'm guessing you paid off some other
debts and then you tackled the house
working the working hour that baby steps
it's known what it sounds like tell me
what happened well we Adam we'd made
some horrible choices in terms of
investing we had taken a second mortgage
out on our house in California and then
tried to move and bought some rental
properties with it and ended up with a
combination of mortgage debt rental
property debt of course credit card debt
in order to pay for all the fix-up on
the Renault Cohen's from you know we had
the car payment and had a fifth-wheel
and did the absolute worst to borrow and
money if you were wrong we were you've
done every stupid thing out there we did
we had it covered definitely meet you
that's how I know what it looks like now
then one of the staff members on staff
introduced us to we went through
financial piece together and we all got
passionate about getting debt free at 6
a.m. on a Monday morning I want you to
know is when they made us do that oh my
god we're not happy the staff and staffs
going through and wives and husbands are
coming over at the church doing
Financial Peace University yes sir six
years and seven months ago yes and that
started the process it did it did so
what was the first thing that happened
when you two were sitting there watching
those videos going through this class
well we were in denial actually for how
much money we actually owed I didn't
want to put everything down because it
was embarrassing yeah
even to yourself yeah so that's the
first so you sit down you have that that
first come-to-jesus budget meeting where
all the numbers come out and you have an
oh my god moment yes yeah tell me what
happened well we we started attacking
the credit card debt during the debt
snowball paying off the the little
things and realized we had to sell
things so we started having garage sales
and sold cars and sold them at the fifth
wheel actually sold one of the rental
cars rental houses in order to pay off
our friends and about then we thought
everything was going to screech to a
halt because our son was dying our 17
year old son was diagnosed with leukemia
oh my gosh and so we looked at we did
the wrong thing and looked at the
Internet to see how much it was going to
cost and thought we were going to go
into bankruptcy because everything we
read said it was going to be between one
and two million dollars or the medical
expenses and so we spent almost six
months going back and forth to Houston
to MD Anderson for his treatment about
the the four-month point he almost died
and it just changed our life because we
thought how are we gonna get debt-free
with all these medical bills following
us but when you have a sick child we
would have done anything actually look
that was no longer concerned we would
have sold yeah we would have gone into
bankruptcy sure that was not a concern
absolutely but because of having been
through financial piece we had already
made some changes to our health
insurance plan and so the insurance
policy covered all the debt our friends
who knew what we were doing got together
and helped raise some money because it
was costing us money for food
sure harking and lodging while we were
in Easton gas to run back and forth yes
and so even through that God protected
us and we came out of that and we're
able to start right back up and really
what made the difference is we made the
decision to begin selling off our rental
properties to get that free and finally
the market in California turned around
enough so that this this past fall we
were able to sell our California house
not only pay off all the the other debt
that we had on the rental properties but
also pay off our mortgage and put five
months of emergency fund in the bank and
save enough to come to Nashville
Tennessee
Wow how old is he now he's 22 now just
turned 22 how's he doing
he's doing very well he's almost to his
five-year mark at five years they call
him cured and or a year away from that
phrase he's headed to nursing school
because he wants to be a bad pediatric
nurse I bet he does yeah and he'd be one
of the best ones on the planet after
going through that Wow
so praise God and MD Anderson yeah save
the kid's life yeah oh man like you guys
didn't have enough to do Wow
but the Lord is faithful yeah when you
say you multiply it by God that's really
what happened is it was an impossible
situation that he completely took care
of yeah and this has become a neat part
of our story because just even going
diligently through the process of paying
off our debt God's been faithful every
step of the way with extra jobs when we
needed it and and special things of
encouragement when we needed yeah but
how about going through the health
insurance lesson and knowing enough to
make sure you have the right health
insurance just in time I have to say the
insurance one is not my favorite one
yeah but now and so we're we're actually
running two classes right now two
foundations class for our college
students and then a regular one for our
Sunday School class and so we tell them
you need to hang in there through the
insurance one
yes it made the difference in our life
oh really
we raised our cap on that and that's
otherwise we'd still owe a million
anyhow your maximum amount of pocket got
raised and that changed everything and
we did that Wow unbelievable man it's
vintage euros you wonder sir
you guys aren't you guys were heroes
what a great story we're great what a
great thing you've walked through and
you've done it with victory I love it
thank you for being bold enough to tell
people the truth Wow we bought the lie
and we were going into death thinking
that was the way to live and the freedom
it's hard for people to understand how
excited we are about being debt-free
we're debt-free and we're cancer-free
yes all in the same year yes I mean the
five-year mark oh my gosh this is just
the best of the best of all things
Wow Wow Wow and now what can you do with
no payments you don't even have a house
payment you do not you're weird yes we
are actually officially it's amazing how
does it feel amazing and one of the
things that you talk about so much is
the ability to give and so we feel like
we've always tried to give but it's not
the same as when you're giving and you
don't have to worry about it and so we
have really enjoyed people gave to us so
openly when our son was sick I mean
that's one of the reasons that we were
able to get through it is because of the
generosity of those around us and now to
beyond the giving side of it is
something that you I couldn't even
understand until we're here so when we
hear you talk about that we understand
what that is yeah you're my house
payment I mean you can drop some coin on
somebody needs bail if it changes
everything I'm live out your faith in a
whole different way congratulations I'm
so proud of y'all I'm so honnor to meet
you wow you are something else all right
it's Brian and Eileen Amarillo Texas
area 617 thousand dollars paid off six
years seven months selling everything
and beating cancer in the process from
60 to 110,000 count it down let's hear a
debt three scream one two three
wow wow wow wow hey you guys Rachael
Cruz here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the
dayroom the channel don't tell them I
said that
I'm kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you